my dad was diagnosed with terminal brain  cancer and then a year later he passed  away and then a day later i went to a  cafe and they were all out of oat milk  ah so it's like pile it on  this is who wants to be my dad my  boyfriend thinks we should split yours  50 50. what do you think about that i  think he gets 100  i'm just gonna take you through the  stages of free oh my god wait i know you  we went to college together hi if i try  hard enough i can feel him all the time  i feel him here wait a minute do you  happen to feel the presence of my past  father next to you yes that's a yes  i was the type of kid who had to get  picked up at sleepovers at 23. mom dad  this guy is not the one  his death changed me every day that we  get is a day to live oh my god  you